everyone around you will appreciate you
if your words match your actions
be the change that you wish to see in
the world
live as if you were to die tomorrow
learn as if you were to live forever
an eye for an eye will only make the
whole world blind
there are many causes
i would die for
there is not a single cause i would kill
for
it is easier to build a boy
than to mend a man
nothing is so aggravating as calmness
non-violence is a weapon of the strong
happiness is when
what you think
what you say
and what you do are in harmony
[Music]
the weak
can never forgive
forgiveness is in the attribute of the
strong
where there is love there is life
freedom is not worth having if it does
not include the freedom to make mistakes
nobody can hurt me without my permission
[Music]
god has no religion
hate the sin
love the sinner
i will not let anyone walk through my
mind with their dirty feet
[Music]
you must not lose faith in humanity
humanity is like an ocean
if a few drops of the ocean are dirty
the ocean does not become dirty
the best way to find yourself
is to lose yourself in the service of
others
the future depends on what you do today
a man is but the product of his thoughts
what he thinks
he becomes
the greatness of a nation
and its moral progress
can be judged by the way its animals are
treated
to give pleasure to a single heart by a
single act
is better than a thousand heads bowing
in prayer
[Music]
each night when i go to sleep
i die
and the next morning when i wake up
i am reborn
earth provides enough to satisfy every
man's needs
but not every man's greed
[Music]
to believe in something
and not to live it is dishonest
[Music]
there are people in the world so hungry
that god cannot appear to them except
in the form of bread
[Music]
whatever you do will be insignificant
but it is very important that you do it
[Music]
the day the power of love overrules the
love of power
the world will know peace
truth never damages a cause that is just
[Music]
whenever you are confronted with an
opponent
conquer him with love
strength does not come from physical
capacity
it comes from
an indomitable will
action expresses priorities
my life
is my message
you don't know who is important to you
until you actually lose them
[Music]
i object to violence because when it
appears to do good
the good is only temporary
the evil it does
is permanent
you can chain me
you can torture me
you can even destroy this body
but you will never imprison my mind
if i had no sense of humor
i would long ago have committed suicide
you may never know what results come of
your actions
but if you do nothing
there will be no results
love is the strongest force the world
possesses
and yet it is the humblest imaginable
the simplest acts of kindness
are by far more powerful than a thousand
heads bowing in prayer
silence becomes cowardice
when occasion demands speaking out the
whole truth
and acting accordingly
they cannot take away our self-respect
if we do not give it to them
a coward is incapable of exhibiting love
it is the prerogative of the brave
in a gentle way
you can shake the world
speak only if it improves upon the
silence
there is no school equal to a decent
home
and no teacher equal to a virtuous
parent
i cannot conceive of a greater loss than
the loss of one's self-respect
to my mind
the life of a lamb is no less precious
than that of a human being
in doing something
do it with love
or never do it at all
i call him religious who understands the
suffering of others
poverty is the worst form of violence
there is no way to peace
there is only peace
seek not greater wealth but simpler
pleasure
not higher fortune
but deeper felicity
truth is one
paths are many
[Music]
always aim at purifying your thoughts
and everything will be well
i believe in the fundamental truth of
all great religions of the world
[Music]
yes i am
i am also a muslim
a christian
a buddhist
and a jew
[Music]
my imperfections and failures
are as much a blessing from god
as my successes and my talents
and i lay them both at his feet
faith is not something to grasp
it is the state to grow into
believe in equality for everyone
except reporters and photographers
each one has to find his peace from
within
and peace to be real
must be unaffected by outside
circumstances
our ability to reach unity in diversity
will be the beauty and the test of our
civilization
[Music]
a no
uttered from the deepest conviction
is better than a yes
merely uttered to please
or worse to avoid trouble
i want freedom for the full expression
of my personality
it is wrong and immoral to seek to
escape the consequences of one's acts
if we are to reach real peace in the
world
we shall have to begin with the children
prayer is not an old woman's idol
amusement
properly understood and applied
it is the most potent instrument of
action
what barrier is there that love cannot
break
the greatness of humanity is not in
being human
but in being humane
fearlessness is the first requisite of
spirituality
cowards can never be moral
there is no such thing as too insane
unless others turn up dead
due to your actions
[Music]
the difference between what we do and
what we are capable of doing would
suffice to solve most of the world's
problems
the path is the goal
[Music]
liberty and democracy become unholy when
their hands are dyed red with innocent
blood
everyone around you will appreciate you
if your words match your actions
[Music]
honest differences are often a healthy
sign of progress
nothing has saddened me so much in life
as the hardness of heart
of educated people
you will never get angry if you keep
silent more often
satisfaction lies in the effort
not in the attainment
full effort is full victory
it's easy to stand in the crowd but it
takes courage to stand alone
true beauty lies in the purity of the
heart
you cannot shake hands with a clenched
fist
there would be nothing to frighten you
if you refuse to be afraid
[Music]
love never claims
it ever gives
love ever suffers
never resents
never revenges itself
the moment there is suspicion about a
person's motives
he does becomes tainted
wherever you are
will always be in my heart
non-violence which is the quality of the
heart
cannot come by and appeal to the brain
champions are made from something they
have deep inside of them
a desire
a dream
a vision
in matters of conscience
the law of the majority has no place
no one can ride on the back of a man
unless it is bent
true morality consists not in following
the beaten track
but in finding the true path for
ourselves
and fearlessly following it
if you don't find god in the next person
you meet
it is a waste of time looking for him
further
where love is
their god is also
[Music]
you